hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast a platform to digitize
biology a potential pathway to
exponential medicine presented by dr.
John McDevitt we're excited to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab Roos the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
for more information please go to www
boots com I'm Kristina jewel of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or you can use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the c/e button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce dr. John McDevitt dr.
McDevitt is a pioneer in the development
of the program programmable bio nano
chip pbmc sensor systems these chip
based sensors have laid the foundation
for the efficient collection of first in
kind wellness and disease signatures for
the areas of adjunctive oral cancer
tests as well as for cardiac wellness
profiles McDevitt has displayed a strong
track record of translating essential
bioscience discovery
into real-world clinical practice he
serves as a scientific founder and chief
scientific officer for sensitive a
diagnosed a diagnostic company committed
to the development of affordable medical
micro device technologies dr. McDevitt
currently serves as the chair for the
biomaterials department at New York
University's College of Dentistry
McDevitt and his team have written more
than 200 peer-reviewed scientific
manuscripts and have contributed to more
than a hundred patents and patent
applications in addition to the 2016
AACC Wallace Age culture lecture ship
award this work was recognized with the
best of what's new award in the medical
device category by popular science as
well as for the best scientific advances
award by the science coalition please
join me in welcoming dr. John McDevitt I
will now turn the presentation over to
him dr. McDevitt
you
Kristi thank you so much for that kind
introduction good afternoon everyone
pleasure to have an opportunity to speak
with you today today's medical system is
complex expensive and inefficient it
requires a huge infrastructure
sophisticated equipment complex sample
handling and tons and tons of paperwork
one size fits all we need a better way
forward but this is the past and today
we'll speak about the future the
programmable bio nano chip system is a
platform to digitize biology using
sensors that learn for the first time
will be in a position to capture
diseases early before they spiral out of
control now my presentation today will
take us into a journey where we'll look
at three specific areas first I'll
introduce the core technology the
programmable bio nano chip system then
we'll look at the training of this
device again this is a sensor that
learns in the curriculum so to speak
that all talk about today relates to two
clinical applications one for oral
cancer and the second for a risk
assessment related to cardiac heart
disease I'll end my talk with a brief
discussion about how this science and
engineering has a potential impact on
the road to exponential medicine and
I'll define what I mean by that at that
point okay so let's jump in
so let's begin with the topic of
convergence there are five main areas
that are combined here for the first
time to create these sensors that learn
these are point of care microfluidics
biomarker discovery artificial
intelligence and mobile health the
diagnostic industry as we all know today
is poised for change we need the iphone
of medicine but how do we get there well
we begin with non-invasive sampling and
that allows us to do testing just about
anywhere and then we have a programmable
lab card and that's key for allowing us
to bring in new content as needed from
the omics discoveries etc then we have a
diagnostic node that puts us in a global
setting and then we bring into play
algorithms and mobile health tools which
together allow us to take complex
biomarker information and reduce it to a
an intuitive single number index that
goes directly to the patient and the
health care provider alike
let's take a look underneath the hood of
the instrumentation there are two major
parts that come together here a lab card
and an analyzer the analyzer serves as a
mechanical software and an optics
interface the lab card is inserted into
the analyzer to complete the test and at
the end of the process light-emitting
diodes flash and are used to create
fluorescent images that allow us to
digitize biology
so we have one platform with many
clinical functions and this is a lab
card sized entity which has as its guts
a chip region which allows us to create
two different configurations the one in
the upper center is a membrane and that
capture cells and the second one is a
bead array that allows us to do soluble
chemistry's so the key is that both of
these configurations fit within that
same lab card and interface with an
analyzer ultimately replacing the
functionality of all the different
instruments that you see in this view
graph
you
let's take a closer look at both the lab
card configurations next starting with
the membrane based system initially a
couple drops of fluid containing the
cell suspension is introduced into the
lab card capillary forces draw it into
the interior then the right hand Lister
drives the cell suspension to the top of
the lab card where the cells are
captured next the left-hand blister
forces fluid through a reagent pad rida
solving a red agreeing in a blue reagent
the cells move through this process
towards the top of the lab card where
they are caught in one focal plane the
region cocktail comes in and stains the
individual cells hitting the nucleus the
cytoplasm and a variety of different
surface markers using this process high
content single cell analysis is
completed at the point single cell
analyses are created at the point of
care
so so net next let's take a look at the
bead base configuration next let's take
a look at the bead base configuration of
the lab card the front end is basically
the same and it's not shown here rather
what we focus it on is the magic of
biomarker capture the bead serves as a
micro sponge with an a no net and is
coated with a high concentration of a
capture antibody in this case the
pentameric protein CRP is shown in this
sequence being sequestered from the
solution at this initial stage we don't
see it at that first stage and it's not
until we bring in the detection antibody
this case coated with green fluorophores
that were able to visualize the presence
of this protein at the very end of the
assay win the green light emitting diode
flashes so how did we get here well this
particular slide gives you a sense of
the three major steps that we took we
began with basic science and engineering
the discovery aspects this took a decade
and then we ran a series of clinical
trials that all feature here in a second
and more recently we begun the process
of scaling so in the diagnostic industry
I think as everyone can imagine there's
there's no shortcuts here lives are at
stake and we need to be absolutely sure
that we have good quality results and so
this is part of the rigor that we've
taken to develop these devices but I
would say one of the good things about
having done all this and this is
represented in these green arrows is
this basically 15 years of activity is
now behind us and we're in a position
where we can accelerate and move
much more quickly for the next stages
I'll come back to this point at the very
end of the presentation when we talk
about the pathway to exponential
medicine so we've now run a series of
different clinical trials with a large
number of patients for a number of
different areas six major trials over
5,000 patients ten clinical sites many
biomarkers all using non-invasive
sampling and the purpose of this is to
identify the appropriate patient
populations and bring in new content and
new fingerprints that can capture
diseases earlier on then what has been
done in the past and that would be a
main theme of my talk today so it starts
with these clinical trials so how does
the system work well it's much like a
glucometer in that we have no pipetting
step we've simply put a drop of a bodily
fluid on a target zone and then
everything else happens within the lab
card and within the associated
instrument and we've spent over a
hundred percent years in engineering the
capture of biomarker so it's now very
efficient in this miniaturized format
and it gives us results on the time
course of a doctor's visit more
importantly we're able to secure lab
quality results at the point of care so
miniaturization doesn't cost us in terms
of performance now throughout my talk I
will make reference to a couple peer
reviewed publications and at the very
end I'll send a link out to to all of
our publications but the first one deals
with the core technology and is
published in lab on a chip so let's
switch gears here a little bit now and
move into the second area about the
clinical training of this sensor that
learns and I want to focus your
attention
not on the plurality of chips but more
specifically to the oral cancer
applications that's at the lower right
hand corner of this particular slide the
yellow chip the oral cancer one is where
we'll go to next now oral cancer is one
of the most expensive of all the cancers
to treat and it also has one of the
worst outcomes and unfortunately for
people getting oral cancer the outcomes
have not increased much over the last
five decades now the good news is when
the disease is caught early the outcomes
are actually quite good but we don't
have an effective means to bring in
screen or we don't have an effective
adjunct test now to capture the disease
early so we needed to innovate and we
needed to put together a new type of
study that has never been done
previously in order to gather enough
information so that we could look across
all the different diagnostic categories
so with funding coming from a special
program from the NIH a grand opportunity
program we were able to create of one of
a kind trial that has the structure that
I show you here I won't go into the
minutia but rather focus on the key
aspect here of getting over a thousand
patients and in doing so this gave us
the granularity to spread it across all
the different diagnostic categories
which is key for for our next steps so
this brought us into the area of big
data and we were able to create one of
the largest if not the largest database
of cell-based measurements ever created
for potentially malignant oral lesions
so with these thousand patients about
two thousand cells per patients we
individually analyze these cells through
18 million of them with over a hundred
and fifty image based parameters to
create this huge database and this
allowed us to do data warehousing data
mining and ultimately the predictive
modeling that all feature in a second so
let me just put this task into
perspective and give you a sense of what
we needed to do in this particular trial
now if the task was to distinguish
between normal or benign and malignant
that would be very simple and in fact if
you look at the bottom of this view
graph you'll see the level of
disagreement between the gold standard
pathologist so we had a number for
different pathologist across our trial
and the level of disagreement is shown
there and one thing that's striking
about this is in the middle in the
dysplasia reason region in the pre
cancer we see very significant
disagreement so let me focus your
attention to panel B where there are a
number of numbers here and there are
seven different diagnostic categories
that are mapped out moving from normal
to benign 23 flavors of displays your
cancer institute and ultimately
malignancy now these different areas
i'll come back to in those numbers in
particular what i want to focus your
attention on is the 23 split that's the
benign mild split and that's really
where we want to capture these patients
early on in the disease evolution
process where the outcomes for these
patients are quite good
so with this gold standard the
pathologist and the H&E staining of a
scalpel biopsy as being the means to
make this diagnosis we have a problem
the individual pathologist is what a
patient would normally have access to
but we found that there was disagreement
and we are training a new device and we
wanted to have a higher level of
certainty of where these patients were
so in this trial we need to innovate and
the innovation came with respect to how
we adjudicated these samples how we
define the truth and it's been known for
some time that if you crowdsource
decisions you actually make much better
decision than if you rely on one
individual and although we were relying
on the best pathologist in the world to
make our diagnostic calls that was not
good enough we needed to develop
something even better than that and so
what we created was an enhanced gold
standard and I won't go into the gory
detail of this today but rather to
mention that there are four levels of
the Jude occation i'll give you a link
to the paper so you can look into this
more deeply innocence in a after this
presentation but the key theme for this
talk is that we started with a
sixty-nine percent agreement at the
individual pathologist level and after
these four levels of judging we went up
to a hundred percent agreement so that's
our starting point now in developing
these diagnostic models and again this
is published in quad quad o last year
and that will serve as the basis for the
training of our algorithms now with this
adjudication process in hand we're now
in a capacity to take the next step and
the next step for us was to acknowledge
and recognize that we do business
differently than
way the pathologist's do their analysis
of these patients samples so at the top
of this view graph is shown the data the
HIV stain on a glass slide for a tissue
slice that a professional pathologist
would look at and you see benign and
malignant and the trained pathologist
can eat this up and go and make this
diagnosis and again this is the easy
diagnosis the the two extremes so with
our chip we needed to learn to speak a
new language and you see the the
vocabulary if you like at the bottom of
this viewgraph the individual cells that
are stained with these three colors that
were shown in that movie and you see a
benign patient in the center and then
with more colorful display the malignant
patient at the lower right so one of the
things that we then did we have this big
data with these 13 million cells
profiled with these 150 imaging
parameters and we had to ask ourselves
how do we make sense of this so we used
machine learning at the individual
metric level first to see what was most
important and this is a
multi-dimensional space which is
unbelievably complex on giving you just
a little slice of of the data but this
particular heat map gives you some key
insights for where the information is
being derived from and we had some
surprises here in some some new biology
that we uncovered with all this data so
at the top of this view graph let me
focus your attention on the biomarkers
and the different diagnostic transitions
the most important one of which again is
this 23 transition and you look at the
heat map and immediately you recognize
the best biomarker for making this
decision
the one that's richest in information
and shows up red-hot is ki67 now that
was not known in the literature
previously but we got a clear indication
that that's the case we also found that
nuclear cytoplasm ratio is good but that
tends to capture the disease late in the
evolution the other surprise from this
is self circularity which wasn't a
dominant variable but it is in fact very
hot and it extends into these early
transitions so that's one view of the
data the other view of the data that i
want to show you and again this is from
the single biomarker perspective is
encoded in this color color encoded
chord diagram and you probably don't
stare at these chord diagrams every day
so let me help you understand how to
navigate this on the right hand portion
of this particular view graph if you can
see my mouse here with the gray cord
here are the different diagnostic
transitions and again let me focus your
attention on the 23 because that's the
one that is clinically most important
and that's on the right hand side on the
left hand side is where the information
comes from and again this is color
encoded the lesion characteristics the
color the size whether or not there's
like and plainness that's encoded in
yellow then we have the nuclear
parameters then the molecular biomarkers
and the morphometric details in red so
looking at the width of the cord you get
some information about where does an
important information come from and
immediately what should strike you for
this early transition is the biomarkers
are dominant part but it's not just
biomarkers it's biomarkers and the other
things in fact it's all of these
categories that contribute to making a
better decision
so what I just showed you was a view of
where the information was coming from
related to the individual biomarkers but
we don't have individual biomarkers we
have big computers in fact we have super
computers that can chomp on all the
different metrics and put them together
into multi marker combinations and so
what what is pulled out now in this
particular view graph is the area's
underneath the receiver operator
characteristic curves which in essence
is a measure of the diagnostic accuracy
the sensitivity the specificity a number
of one sweeps out perfect diagnosis on
both of those metrics now another unique
thing about this trial is that we did
both model development and model
validation in the same trial we had two
sets of statisticians this was run the
way the pharmaceutical industry runs
clinical trials and we separated the
model development from the model
validation so that we could do both both
of these steps in this particular trial
so the before represents model
development the after represents the
picture that we get after we put the
stake in the sand and selected the the
models and one of the key metrics here
is that the area's underneath the curve
are actually quite good they drop only
about four percent in going from model
development to model validation the
average in the literature not the best
but the average in the literature for
this validation step is a loss of 23%
going from an a to a C in terms of a
grade so so we didn't have that happen
we it didn't over fit the data now the
other thing I want to mention is this 2
vs 7 comparison if we simplify the
analysis and say we're going to
look at benign vs cancer and only pull
out the patients with those two
categories we get a diagnostic accuracy
very close to one the area underneath
the quote the curve very very close to
one and so that's really key because it
shows that it's not adequate simply to
look at these two extremes and when we
look at the adjunctive tests that are on
the market today which only cover about
2% of the patients that you'd like to
have these adjuncts and screens on we
just don't get the confidence we don't
get the accuracy we don't have the
granularity yet and it goes back to the
fact that that the way these devices
were trained we're at these two extremes
so we need to look at big data we need
to look at more data channels to get
this level of accuracy and this whole
area of the oral cancer and development
of this new adjunctive test has just
been published recently and we have a
series of other articles following this
this up but the august issue of oral and
ecology has as our first discussion of
the grand opportunity trial okay so so
now let me switch gears here a little
bit to to the area of cardiovascular
disease and this is the the chip again
it looks the same it has a different
color but it has the same form factor
and what I'm doing now is I'm switching
from a cell based test the oral cancer
cell based test into a multiplexed
protein test which is done on a bead
array so cardiac heart disease is in
many ways similar to the oral cancer
application which I've just talked about
in the sense that both of these areas
now focus on late stage disease
diagnosis
our goal in cardiac heart disease is
actually very similar we want to develop
new tools that put a flashlight on the
disease and allow us to look in the dark
dark soda to speak and help to take this
very significant disease which is the
number one killer in the United States
and on a global basis and provide more
effective feedback to patients and
clinicians so that was the basis for us
moving into this particular area and so
we did a lot of the same things that
I've just talked about in fact this
particular trial overlapped in a time
course with the oil cancer program that
I just mentioned this this also was
funded through NIH and it involved a
study where we had a perspective
recruitment of chest pain patients at
two hospitals been talent in the DeBakey
VA center in houston and we collaborated
with the to clinicians here christy
valentin who who's a risk assessment
doctor and also involved in metabolic
syndrome and so to capture disease early
and then became ba skirt is a heart
failure dr. representing the other
extreme so we have four time points to
bodily fluids and 15 biomarkers and this
is really really key is having the
granularity with respect to time now and
we're also with respect to biomarkers
that makes this this effort unique so if
we look now at what's happening in the
cardiac diagnostic industry there's
remote lab point of care and laboratory
developed test now in the remote lab in
the point of care there's there's 20
instruments that are approved by the FDA
the LD teas are not in this category but
19 of 20 of
is approved devices focus on making
measurements of cardiac biomarkers one
at a time so we look at this area as one
in which there's a deficiency and one
that we want to address by developing
new databases that can help to enrich
multi mark or measurements so one of the
things that we did here initially and
this happened before we begin this
thousand patient plus trial it is we
selected biomarkers that span across the
seven stages of the cardiovascular
cascade going from healthy to plaque
formation to destabilise plaque to
rupture to clot formation to ami and
heart failure so today these cardiac
conditions are treated as syndromes
they're not all looked at simultaneously
but what we doing in all our trials now
is taking all the biomarkers that you
see here and putting them into
algorithms into the chip that gathers
the information that we need and
creating algorithms that are specific to
where the patient is at so this
correlation matrix which you see now is
looking at how the cross interactions go
within these biomarkers and while you
see some correlations let's say in the
am I sector here there's a lot of blue
regions which are not very hot hot and
this gives us a sense that we get
different information from these various
biomarkers and that is by design so and
now that the fingerprints will become
key in a minute and we'll get to that in
a second but but let me first talk a
little bit about how the measurements
are acquired with in this particular lab
card so if you look at the top first
you'll see a series of different types
patience extracted from this trial and
these are our representative examples of
what you see for example with a
heart-attack patient the am I patient
here and you sees a series of different
beads myoglobin is lighting up strongly
then ck-mb and then a bit more lightly
because this is at lower concentration
but this is cardiac troponin I the best
best of the biomarkers for a mi now
compare that fingerprint and that
disposition of what these same beads are
doing with a non case so this is part of
the eighty-five percent of false alarms
that that came came in and you see the
chip is pretty dark in this case now we
had a lot of congestive heart failure
patients to coming to the emergency room
with chest pains but in fact twenty four
percent versus fifteen percent for the
am i but we would be able to diagnose
them with a different signature
nt-probnp and myoglobin are strongly lit
up and then we had a decent number of
renal failure patients and cardio renal
syndrome patients and they light up with
yet another part of the chip involving
d-dimer and a huge signal force estat
enci so the point here is all of these
patients came in suspecting a heart
attack but we have different cardiac
indications and we have a severe
coronary artery disease which I'll also
get back to in a second that are
represented in this patient population
so the other thing I want to mention in
addition to the fingerprint as to what
type of patient but also there is a
capacity to pull out specifically the
intensity of fluorescence so this is a
simple chip of troponin I featured at
the center of the chip with many
duplicate beads we don't need this mini
to make a typical measurement but it
shows you this dose dependent
curve and from the fluorescence
intensity what we're able to pull out
from the minimum the fluorescence
intensity Sigma is basically this dose
curve and this dose curve is shown here
with the calculated limit of detection
of 20 picograms which is on order with
some of the best point-of-care troponin
instruments that are on the market today
we also correlate well with large
instruments this is a Siemens dimension
instrument going against the the
miniaturized sensor system that I've
just talked about okay so that is mainly
from the perspective of showing that we
could do a good job from the analytical
performance and next I want want to talk
about the the clinical signatures and
the multi marker models that we were in
the process of developing and in this
particular area I'll feature for them
here the the am I acute coronary
syndrome heart failure and cardiac
wellness now this is taking data first
from the am I population and I'm
providing you a correlation graph that
looks at the cross interactions so the
the twofold interactions between these
different biomarkers initially at the
one hour and so if you focus your
attention on the diagonal where my mouse
is going and where this dotted line is
you'll see an intersection of troponin
with two opponent and this is leading to
an area underneath the curve of about
point eight so this is mapping out what
the literature knows for troponin at one
hour it's not perfect but with our chip
based system we find that we get
improvements which are actually
substantial at the same time point by
combining
a couple biomarkers we bring troponin
with BMP we do better at that at three
hours you see the signal getting richer
again at the diagonal and the same
combination of two biomarkers is looking
even more interesting it's red hot it
and but we also see some other
biomarkers coming into play and the
whole process becomes even more rich at
six hours and then also at 12 hours and
what's interesting about about this is
not only the point of making better
better diagnosis at through a
combination of multiple biomarkers but
also that there's new biology that is
showing itself cardiac remodeling
effects that we will describe in the
literature off into the future so what
I've just described that with the
cardiac area the cardiac am I area the
heart attack I would just look at that
as being the tip of the iceberg and in
fact when we look and compare standard
of care to to what we do with the multi
marker approach we see some improvement
but the improvement is about one and a
half percent better going from 98 and 99
and a half percent but larger increases
in the information come from other areas
and so I want to mention a couple of
them and although I would describe what
we're doing now is just being at the
initial stages in wellness we already
see improvements relative to the
Framingham risk or so we have looked at
Framingham across our our studies and
then also compared with the cardiac
scorecard and again looking at the
area's underneath the curve we get some
increase in performance by combining
some of the traditional risk factors
with these biomarkers
and so this looks at the area's
underneath the curve receiver operating
characteristic curve over here on the
left-hand panel are our scorecard Plus
which is a combination of the biomarkers
and some risk factors outperforms
Framingham and it outperforms the
biomarkers by by themselves so this
model here the cardiac what I would
describe as the cardiac scorecard the
Wellness scorecard is also well
calibrated so as we go up in terms of
the decile of risk as defined by
Framingham wood and other risk
parameters for cardiac heart disease we
also see that scale for the cardiac
scorecard now we've developed a number
of different algorithms and and the
thing I want to focus on here is the
fact that all of this is happening
within the same lab card right so that
so we've combined these different
biomarkers and we create different
algorithms depending on the setting and
what I'm showing you on this particular
view graph is the logistic regression
beta coefficient which is basically
giving us information about the level of
importance for the different variables
and how this contributes to the four
models that I've spoken to already so if
you focus your attention first on the
ami model the blue triangle here and
look at troponin at the bottom the beta
coefficient is three and this is off
scale good so I'm not going to say
anything nude to people familiar with
cardiac Diagnostics that this is an
unbelievably good biomarker but it's
borne out in the methodologies that
we've chosen here to do this lasso it
logistic regression technique that that
analyzes each subsequent variable and we
don't touch the data it's a conservative
way to do this but it gives us a good
sense of of the fact that we can pull in
additional information a little bit from
BNP and then il-1beta and then when we
look at ACS so 8 acs being am i and
unstable angina that diagnosis challenge
is actually harder troponin does less
well we have more of a reliance on BNP
and the diabetes status also plays a
role then heart failure no surprise here
BNP is the dominant variable troponin
contributes to that but being BNP is
also part of that as well as age the
most point though I want to make on this
view graph though is what is happening
with respect to the wellness model this
is the most complex of all these models
it has the most rich data sources it has
many biomarkers contributing and it has
smoking and and gender is an important
theme but what's interesting here is BMI
is a huge part of the information and
this the BMA BMI is not part of the
Framingham the original Framingham risk
score and so we find this as a key a key
observation and part of our algorithms
so our initial papers in this area are
going out to the machine learning we
have some high-profile clinical
publications following the this up but
but expert systems with application is
where you'll find this initial work so
let me next move to the last topic and
this is the area of the pathway to
exponential medicine and this pathway to
exponential medicine becomes possible by
virtue of creating a diagnostic
platform that digitizes biology and in
this area if we want to go down the
pathway to exponential medicine you need
to go down the pathway that information
technology has gone in the past so you
need to follow the information and it's
not all about counting the number of
calories or the number of steps on your
cell phone and that part is already done
but seventy percent about seventy
percent of clinical decision making is
made with the aid of clinical tests it's
made with the biomarker measurements so
it's about information and we need to
think about where does this come from so
going back historically about accessing
information the cavemen gathered
information from by talking around a
campfire this information came from a
local and linear perspective it was a
couple human beings communicating with
one another in this local environment
and we did a little bit better with the
invention of the printing press and I
say a little bit better now now we have
an ability to distribute books across
the planet but if you have to print them
out and mail them and have someone pay
for that there's a whole bunch of
infrastructure that's in the way that
makes this not a highly scalable
distribution channel but things get
insanely interesting at the next step
and the next step is when information
flows in a digital sense and now we can
move information across the planet at
the speed of light and again this all
becomes possible because of a couple
things because of infrastructure that's
scalable and also the capacity
to digitize information and send it over
a an established network so let's now
consider the process of 30 steps and I
want to make a key point here and will
in the next movie we'll we'll look into
this issue
30 linear steps get you across the
street that is equivalent to about 30
meters that's as far as you go 30
exponential steps yields a journey that
traverses over 1 billion meters humans
are hard-wired to think locally and
linearly it's difficult for us to even
imagine what the impact of an
exponential technology could be each
trip around our planet is about 40
million meters thus our exponential
journey provides us with the capacity to
complete 26 and a half round trips
across the globe so let me go back and
basically narrate what you just saw the
point was 30 linear steps get you across
the street it's about 30 meters 30
exponential steps takes you two to the
30th power which is a bit over a billion
and human beings are hard-wired to think
locally and linearly it's hard for us to
even imagine what that means but but it
is the equivalent of us walking around
the planet or traversing around the
planet or taking a flight around the
planet 26 and a half times so this all
becomes possible when we digitize
biology and so in the last year we begin
to begun to think about what does this
mean what does this mean to us and we
have one diagnostic node that we know we
can look at and make measurements for a
thousand patients so we can begin with a
billion to think about treating a
billion people with a million devices
now a million
sounds like a big number until you
consider today on our planet we have
over 7 billion mobile phones and so
these these tools are moving in a highly
scalable way into all corners of our
planet so so the Diagnostics now we have
to consider the the pathway to
scalability here and this is I would say
at the beginning of the exponential
curve and at the beginning of the
exponential curve that curve looks
linearly but but we are on that
trajectory now and I'm showing you David
versus Goliath here so our programmable
bio nano chip the blue device juxtaposed
to a commercial clinical analyzer and as
we stand today we occupy about 1% of the
volume of this mature device and that
blue box costs about five to ten percent
of the larger scale analyzer so we are
now in the process of thinking about and
building scalable devices and moving
this technology into a number of
different settings and what I've just
described to you today might be thought
of as the Internet of biomarkers and
this tool that can look at many
different biomarkers both that's the
cell the protein level general chemistry
antibody-based test so many different
types of tests now bringing information
in a common format to where it can be
used next and we're now building bridges
to the Internet of Things and I
mentioned one such bridge already which
is body mass index which can be come
from that scale that you see at the top
so so
both both of these things are coming
together in this effort and I think the
fusion of data becomes even more
interesting as we go forward so this
particular pathway of exponential
medicine is elaborated in an article
that was published as a couple months
ago in accounts of chemical research and
you can take a piece peek at that
article if you like so as I move to to
close up my talk I just want to mention
a bit about where we're going our goal
is to move this technology past the
publication and into the real world and
we already have the the devices that you
see here these are now in the bioscience
research sector we've launched a new
company called senza decks and senza
decks is moving this through a number of
different processes so so as I now
summarize my talk and closing up here
before we move on to the questions I
want to leave you with the the big
message here that that we've developed a
platform to digitize biology this is our
attempt to create the iphone of Medicine
which is a bridge between key features
of non-invasive sampling we spent a
decade in the number of programs which I
haven't talked so much about today but
to do small volume of blood sampling
brush biopsies sell very Diagnostics all
coming together in this flexible
platform so that's the front end and
then it's combined with a a programmable
lab card by giving you two examples
today have a yellow chip in a blue chip
that we have many more in the pipeline
which I haven't had a chance to talk
about yet we have a diagnostic node
that is being scaled and miniaturized
further than what I show you here and
then then we are becoming proficient at
building what I might describe as the
netflix of medicine and that is building
algorithms using machine learning and
developing standard protocols for
running trials on the end patient
populations perspective trials with the
probe probe clinical trial strategy and
then then we have mobile health tools we
already have an app on apple's app store
that that can take this all the way over
to the to the patient so with that
you'll see a poll moving in in front of
you and as we move into the question and
answer period you might feel inclined to
take a peek at that and fill that out so
let me turn the moderation back to
Christie and then we'll move into the
question and answer period I really
appreciate your your kind of attention
and look forward to answering your
questions
thank you dr. McDevitt for that
informative presentation okay it's time
for Q&A now if you have a question you'd
like to ask dr. McDevitt please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left in the presentation
window type your question in the box and
click the send button we will answer as
many questions as we have time for okay
let's get started our first question is
okay dr. McDevitt this question is
regarding the reagent is it a closed
system or an open system and what type
of clinical samples can be used Chris
teeth in fact thanks for that question
thanks for the audience to ok so the
reagents are included in the lab card
and I have one here and so this is
credit card size on the back of the lab
card there's a microfluidic circuitry
that includes a couple of glass pads
glass fiber pads into which we deposit
the rage and so the Regents are art
actually put into the lab card in a way
that's analogous to the environment
which exists in an immuno
chromatographic strip so so they are
stabilized for room temperature storage
in the solid state and are reconstituted
during a typical a say so the the other
part of this is the sample and the
sample is depending on the type of test
here so if the
so as an oral cancer test there would be
a psychology brush that would be used by
the dentist to brush the surface of the
red or the white lesion that would be
then transitioned into a little test
tube that creates a cell suspension with
stabilizer and then a little pipette
bulb takes that cell suspension and puts
it into this region of the the lab card
that's then sealed and then that goes
into the analyzer okay so that's so we
have a couple types of samples a cell
suspension for the oral cancer test for
the cardiac test we can use serum we can
use serum saliva or an oral fluid sample
we've run a large trial on both of these
fluids we can use plasma and whole blood
also Christy back to you for the next
question what is the cost of this
instrument and is this instrument
available worldwide
Christie infant fitment think thanks
again and thanks to the audience for the
second question so so we are censored
exes is now in the process of scaling
the device for strategic partners and so
that's what our first release is to the
bioscience research market and while
that is happening there is a parallel
effort to take a number of the test into
a regulated environment onto the pathway
to to the FDA but but we have a series
of a series of releases that are
anticipated in the next couple years and
at this particular moment I'm not in a
position to to state the exact cost of
these instruments but but it is ten
percent ish of the cost of larger
commercial instruments and and again the
research market will will be the first
release is christina or Christina back
to you thanks dr. McDevitt now does it
require a PCR operation
so for a liga nucleotide testing we've
done a number of different things we've
done pcr continuous flow pcr on a chip
to to amplify and then deliver that to
molecular beacons that does the
detection at the back end of that so
that that area is not our number one
focus right now and so we have
compatibility we've published the data
in this particular space but but we will
be looking at cell based tests in the
oncology space the cardiac area and
trauma drugs of abuse these are all
areas that we published in we but but
the DNA based tests would follow after
that Christine or Christie back to you
thanks dr. McDevitt your time for maybe
two more questions so let's go with this
question what are the regulatory
pathways to move these devices into the
clinic
ah thanks again for that follow-up
questions so so that the regulatory
pathway as you might imagine depends on
the application area and one of the
reasons that we are pushing out the
bioscience research area first is we see
a compelling need to to do this first
and so we don't have a regulatory
barrier but one of the things I did
while I was in Houston as I served as
the director of the Gulf Coast
consortium on early disease detection
and one of the interesting things about
that exercise is it paired us with over
a hundred clinicians that had in any
cases interesting biomarkers moving on
the pathway to publication but so few of
them would move to that next level and
the the lack of regulatory approval for
new biomarkers it is stunning it's it's
almost embarrassing for the scientific
community and part of the reason for
this and what came out of our study of
this pathway is that there's three steps
there's a discovery of a validation and
a clinical implementation and the
discovery might in the protein area
could be done with a mass spec and the
next step is to use an Eliza played
after you've Harvard it's harvested some
antibodies and then at the final
clinical implementation it's on a
commercial analyzer or on a communicant
graphic strip so so three different
instruments three different steps three
different groups often three different
sets of lawyers and a lack of continuity
and people just don't like to deal with
that and so this issue of it's a great
question about the regulatory pathway
and so we've thought a lot about this
and about how do we can create a highway
how do we create a highway for
biomarkers to not that this is going to
go 60 miles an hour and initially but
how can we make that process more
efficient because the people that are
making these discoveries in many cases
are not bio engineers their their BIOS
scientists or clinicians understanding
the biomarker piece so so we feel our
most important contribution at the next
stage is actually handing off this blue
blue box which is behind me over over
here to two individuals that that are in
the trenches and doing biomarker
discovery and and so that that
particular process has the capacity to
save 50 million dollars in five years
which is basically what it took us to
build that blue box that to prime the
pump soda to speak to make sure that
this blue box has an FDA approval by the
time people have completed their their
studies we are nucleating and building a
series of in in the cardiac area where
we're going through a pathway of
individual biomarkers with a 510 K
pathway to get to get them initially
through the process with a gold standard
that's we would be substantially
equivalent to and that's not a big
regulatory barrier and then we would
create the combinations after that the
oral cancer is a little bit different
and we are anticipating a de novo 510 K
pathway that would would take that that
test ultimately into a
chairside point-of-care measurement so
so Christi bet bet back to you that will
have to be our last question as we are
out of time we want to thank you again
dr. McDevitt for your presentation you
have any final comments for our audience
Kristi thanks again for moderating this
this session I'd also want to thank
everyone today for attending this
lecture I think you've just seen the the
the poll results which is giving you a
real-time sense of where people feel the
this technology may have some utility I
would be thrilled to death if we could
establish new relationships to help you
and feel free to contact me via email
there's been a couple links that have
been put put out and love to correspond
with you going forward thank you so much
thank you again dr. John McDevitt before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through februari 2017
and you will receive an email from lab
roads letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now we thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye bye